- WHEN YOU LOOK AT ME,
YOU PROBABLY SEE A GUY
WHO HAS IT ALL.
BUT REALLY, THERE'S A LARGE
PART OF ME THAT'S IMMATURE
AND UNDER-DEVELOPED.
ESPECIALLY WHEN
IT COMES TO WOMEN.
EVERY GIRL I LIKED GROWING UP
REJECTED ME.
AND BECAUSE OF THAT,
I'VE GROWN INTO A MAN
WHO'S CHRONICALLY
NERVOUS AROUND WOMEN.
I'M AN EMOTIONAL MIDGET.
NOW, IF SOMEONE CAME TO ME
WITH THIS PROBLEM,
I'D SUGGEST IMMERSION THERAPY,
WHERE YOU OVERWHELM YOURSELF
WITH YOUR FEAR IN ORDER
TO OVERCOME IT.
SO TONIGHT,
TO INSPIRE YOU,
I'M GOING TO ATTEMPT TO OVERCOME
MY FEAR OF THE OPPOSITE SEX
BY DATING NOT ONE,
BUT TEN WOMEN AT THE SAME TIME.
WISH ME LUCK.
I NEEDED TO GET TEN WOMEN
TO AGREE TO DATE ME,
SO I THOUGHT IT WOULD BE EASY
TO START WITH SOMEONE
I WORK WITH.
SO...
YOU KNOW HOW I'M DOING
THE THING ON THE SHOW
WHERE I'M DATING, LIKE,
TEN WOMEN AT THE SAME TIME?
- YEAH.
- ARE YOU IN A RELATIONSHIP
RIGHT NOW?
- YES.
- OKAY.
- UM...
- SO--SORRY, NEVER MIND.
I WAS STUPID TO ASK.
IT DIDN'T WORK,
AND I KNEW FROM EXPERIENCE
THAT WOMEN JUST WOULDN'T
STOP AND TALK TO ME
WITHOUT AN EXCUSE.
SO I FOUND ONE.
EXCUSE ME, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO TRY OUR NEW
BLUEBERRY-RASPBERRY SMOOTHIE?
COME ON, JUST ONE?
WOULD YOU LIKE TO TRY
ONE OF OUR NEW
RASPBERRY-BLUEBERRY SMOOTHIES?
UH, I'M JUST
KIDDING, ACTUALLY.
I DON'T WORK HERE.
MY NAME'S NATHAN.
I'M JUST DOING THIS
AS A WAY TO BREAK THE ICE
AND SHOW MY PERSONALITY.
- OH.
- I'M JUST TRYING
TO MEET PEOPLE AND--
NO.
I'M JUST DRINKING
MY OWN SMOOTHIE
THAT I BOUGHT FROM HERE.
BUT I LIKE DRINKING MY SMOOTHIE
OUT OF LITTLE CUPS ON A TRAY.
THAT'S HOW I LIKE
TO DRINK MY SMOOTHIE.
OKAY, WELL I THINK I'M ALLOWED
TO DRINK MY SMOOTHIE
WHEREVER I WANT.
- YOU NEED TO MOVE THIS.
- HEY!
- YOU CANNOT TOUCH MY TRAY,
THAT IS CRAZY.
THE SMOOTHIE THING
WAS TOO GIMMICKY ANYWAYS,
AND IT FELT THE SAME WAY
WHEN I USED A CUTE DOG.
DO YOU LIKE MY DOG?
- YEAH.
- SAY HI.
- HI.
- BUT JUST WHEN
I WAS READY TO QUIT,
IT HIT ME.
I HAD A MAJOR GIRL MAGNET
AT MY DISPOSAL
THAT I WAS TOTALLY IGNORING.
A TELEVISION CREW.
IT WAS A CRAZY IDEA,
BUT MAYBE WOMEN WOULD DATE ME
JUST FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE ON TV.
I HAD MY SOLUTION.
I WAS GOING TO CREATE
A FAKE REALITY SHOW
IN WHICH TEN WOMEN WOULD VIE
FOR THE HEART OF ONE MAN.
ME.
IT WOULD BE CALLED
THE HUNK.
IT TOOK WEEKS TO PREPARE
AS WE SORTED THROUGH
THE COUNTLESS SUBMISSIONS
FROM WOMEN TO MY ONLINE AD.
OH, I LIKE HER.
BUT PRETTY SOON WE SELECTED
THE TEN WOMEN I WOULD NEED,
HIRED A HOST,
AND RENTED A MANSION.
NO ONE KNEW MY SHOW
WAS FAKE, NOT EVEN THE HOST.
AND IT WAS
ABOUT TO BEGIN.
- I'M ANTHONY NAPOLI.
TONIGHT, TEN WOMEN
WILL GATHER IN THIS HOUSE
TO VIE FOR THE HEART
OF ONE MAN.
WILL THEY FIND LOVE?
WILL THEY FIND THEIR SOUL MATE?
I'M ANTHONY NAPOLI.
THIS IS THE HUNK.
[romantic music]
♪
- HI.
- YOU READY, NATHAN?
- UH, YEAH.
YEAH, I THINK SO.
- A LITTLE BIT NERVOUS?
- UM, KINDA, YEAH.
- WELL, IT'S TIME
TO MEET THE WOMEN.
- WHERE--WHAT
ARE YOU GONNA DO?
- I'M GONNA STAND HERE,
AND I'M GONNA INTRODUCE YOU
TO ALL THE WOMEN.
- COULD YOU MAYBE,
UM, BE INSIDE FOR THAT?
- I'LL HAVE--
- JUST BECAUSE YOU'RE
VERY HANDSOME COMPARED TO ME.
- I UNDERSTAND THAT, NATHAN--
- COULD YOU BE INSIDE?
- I'LL HAVE TO BE HERE.
- IF YOU'RE NEXT TO ME,
THEY'RE GONNA
LOVE YOU MORE THAN--
- NATHAN, YOU'RE THE HUNK,
I'M THE HOST.
- WOMEN MUST LOVE YOU, RIGHT?
- EH...
- YES?
- I GUESS THEY DO.
- HOW MANY WOMEN
HAVE YOU SLEPT WITH?
- EH...
NOT THAT MANY.
- HAVE YOU EVER HAD A THREESOME?
- I HAVE, YES.
- OKAY, SO--YEAH,
GO INSIDE, PLEASE.
- WOULD YOU--YOU WOULD
LIKE ME TO STEP INSIDE?
- YEAH. YOU CAN'T
BE OUT HERE AT ALL.
- NO, THAT'S ALL RIGHT.
- OKAY, CAN YOU GO INSIDE?
- SURE.
- OKAY. THANK YOU.
I REALIZED TOO LATE
THAT HIRING A HANDSOME HOST
WAS A BAD IDEA.
BUT EVEN WITH TONY IN THE HOUSE,
WHEN THE WOMEN ARRIVED,